I like it I like it a lot okay yeah good
same music let's do it let's do around
where we don't kill each other okay okay
yeah for like an entire ten minutes Wow
I got a deagle in an m16 you're all
gonna [ __ ] die I mean we're gonna not
kill you is your crude under your name
sir yeah well that's because someone
shot me guys they're all healthy I'm
glad you guys have been eating your
vegetables
Anthony is reputable yeah [ __ ] that guy
he's not rebel what I know not in my
book buddy shoot me I'm in a said he
[ __ ] shot me for no reason
hell man yeah what's crazy no it's Kenda
it's it's bits
yeah you sit in a corner with a sniper
rifle what are you doing over there
buddy
no I'm not I'm innocent right it's
[ __ ] it's against the Ian he has
instead of where it is entire out it was
not me
don't kill someone I've never I've never
been the terrorist Oh give it up
terrorists must hunt that terrorist
never kill him never to say never come
on out terrorists ow - oh sorry I
thought your pubes you guys are [ __ ]
teaming up on each other and I don't
like hey I worked as a team here yeah
okay let's work as a team no no or
against you you can't be on the team
you're you're a traitor you can't be in
our cool kids club kids okay [ __ ] outta
[ __ ] you gotta ask you two other
questions that only non traders would
know okay okay I got him cornered where
I'm here by the trees oh no come on can
I shoot me there's a lot of trees
I've attended back up towards the
mountain oh that's weird there's a
there's a dead body there by the trees
no they are there totally do keep their
oh my god someone's gonna die here look
look look he's laying on the ground he's
still on the ground
[Laughter]
how's he doing that how do you do that
how does he hacks the game though the
and even lay on the ground and play dead
guy you're never gonna trust me again
them so whatever trust me how did you
make and do that I would unlock that do
I need to be level two yeah Anthony what
you just shot me right away I knew [ __ ]
I don't know I suppose I just felt
trigger yeah yeah well I'm still
preparing I was a Snoke smoke grenade I
see how it is okay they'll not okay your
knife back smoke come out good still we
gotta put them down yes smoke grenade
[Applause]
wow wow defend myself and off why are
you shooting already
why you shooting already why are you
shooting me why are you running away
okay it wasn't it wasn't Ian but but
wait let me finish let me finish let me
finish
it wasn't come on oh my god I feel so
terrible
[Applause]
although try being like not nice so I
thought I'd just kill you guys right
away smoke being my cover and everything
yeah oh the smoke was your covered yeah
damn it my life have been no star never
time things on there okay
twice why is throwing throwing smoke
something I don't like it
okay I'm innocent I'm innocent I'm the
traitor I'm the traitor tell me great
come at me bro what the [ __ ] why every
round god man
he was it he's not the tree oh no
[ __ ] [ __ ] leanthony know what why me
it's totally I swear to god he's
laughing in a way that I've only ever
heard him laugh yes that was that speech
about laughing you guys are so [ __ ]
sneaky I feel violated oh god oh god
yeah it's awesome I was so I'll it oh I
can be a table and spinach [ __ ] look at
this [ __ ] it looks like I'm trying to
walk it slow take it away from me get
away from me you look great today would
you like a patty patty
I mean krabby patty Oh
Ian is not holding a krabby patty I
think is innocent I mean I know welcome
with a krabby patty I can't pick up the
crabby guys don't let him pick me pick
it up either can I take your order
yeah what I would like a krabby patty
there you go no how you figure that's a
very nice hat you have there sir thank
you very much man well looks like we're
all worship
these crabby patties that we're doing
that's not for sure that's what we were
doing
yeah please calm down
let's see bargain not me I swear to God
sorry squ [ __ ] everybody I'm making this
a feral dance a dance barrel dance yes
whirring so I'm not gonna say it
suspicious or you think but you know we
could all see we already just turns
running we just want to give you a
krabby patty come here come here aren't
you hungry are you hungry for a krabby
patty hey how you doing no it's not me I
swear you're not proving guilt
non-guilty until you're dead so problem
wait no is Candice all right everyone
this is buddy that wasn't good kid that
was good
oh yeah stop it I'm gonna make his head
really bloody come on guys yeah not the
face he got the face now you use a
weapon like a thumb fits perfectly
whatever Yin is doing right now it's
that tab it's see if you're the
terrorist to put him down
oh you click on it hit behind me that's
my only chance to play as the traitor
this music this music please oh what's
wrong with me hey what's fabulous oh no
Philip better
dance let's all hold him on my window
since then I didn't mean to drop a nice
play I think it's a scary here
it's Anthony cuz he moved weird
he moved weird I do weird yeah stay
together stay together
it'll trust you it's whoever got the
crab are no silly toast Kenneth Kenneth
and it's Canada you know it are you
feeling one of the crowbars right what
is wrong with you guys look at the run
you know you killed me see I was
innocent
what do you kill her did you kill that's
right is the only one I try to get away
so it's like this gun like a little
traitor that is talking about your crazy
get back here all right you guys are
your guys are weird you guys are weird
okay it might be Ken he was the first
one to get a crowbar and start attacking
people no no yes what are you talking
about I don't I would never heard a song
in your hand I don't know that's so
weird
[ __ ] it's not what huh teleport spit -
your turn green green [ __ ] that's a bomb
Oh what the [ __ ] is teleported let's go
what is that [ __ ] like the sooner you
just accept this the better it is for
everyone
oh it's all eat dodges you want you want
some of this you want some of this damn
it Billy what was that teleporter back
go for it back off back off or else arm
it back off or I'll army back off from
this farm is what the [ __ ] I seize it
Bollywood oh how did you find it out no
I said as you stood there for so long
you never stand there can't believe I
armed the c-4 and I was like it's gotta
be going off and I'm too close guys
humping in the other room the game a
little shielding your back
that's so weak I mean we would never
guys like that don't worry about being
gay